Hey, Changmin. Can you do me a favor?
Sure, I'd be happy to. What's wrong?
Well, I've been having a lot of trouble with my computer lately.
I'm not very good with computers, so I don't really know what to do.
I see. What is going wrong?
It keeps shutting down whenever I open up a certain program.
Uh-oh. That doesn't sound very good. You might have a virus.
Have you had your computer checked for viruses?
Viruses? No, I haven't. Would you mind checking my computer for viruses?
Sure, I have a program on a disk that will help.
Why don't I go home and get it,...
...then we can meet up and try using it on your computer?
That sounds great, Changmin. I really appreciate your help!
I owe you big.